we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P I love this voicemail
this is this is sort of a response to
vaccines don't work because Colin Powell
died this is really nicely done take a
listen to this
Mr Pacman sir I have proof that helmets
don't work
there was somebody who was in a
motorcycle accident and they were
wearing a helmet and they still died
therefore we know that helmets don't
work and they're just implementing these
helmet laws in order to divide us right
as Americans I think that you should
know that uh and everybody should know
that because we got to play for our
freedoms
thank you sir very very well done very
well done and at this point I mean
listen we've said everything that we can
say about the death of Colin Powell from
a political and a medical standpoint
we've covered the weaponization foaming
at the mouth anti-vaxxerism that has
resulted from the death of Colin Powell
and this is sort of like a nice uh nice
nice cherry on top we have such a good
bonus show for you today we may actually
record and archive this one the NHL has
suspended San Jose Sharks player Evander
Kane for 21 games because he submitted a
fake coveted vaccination card he forged
one and submitted it is 21 games even a
strict enough punishment and was he
suspended with or without pay we will
talk about all of those we will talk
about all those details on today's bonus
show secondly uh right wing
um
social media influencer and radio host
Dan bongino is now threatening to quit
his radio show over the company's
vaccine mandate now he also works for
Fox News he's not said anything about
Fox news's vaccine mandate which is one
of the strictest of any company we're
aware of we will talk about what's going
on with bongino and lastly right now
even though globally coveted cases are
declining even though in the U.S coveted
cases are declining the United Kingdom
has one of the highest coveted infection
rates in the world we will talk about
why on today's bonus show don't miss the
bonus show every day we do another show
it's an extra show we've got this hour
show that you're watching or listening
to right now and then we do another show
I'm joined by producer Pat where we talk
about more stories you can access the
bonus show by becoming a member at
joinpakman.com it's easy it's quick it
probably takes a minute for someone of
average computer skill
joinpakman.com we have a discount code
it'll save you money better 21 use it if
you want or not it's your choice
completely your choice not only do you
get access to the bonus show as a member
you also get a commercial free audio
stream of the show Daily a commercial
free video stream of the show Daily and
when we do our viewer Town Halls as we
did last night
members get priority it's almost like
TSA pre-check for the live Town Halls
or I don't know you know uh use whatever
analogy you want a lot of great member
benefits sign up at joinpakman.com we
will see you on the bonus show and it'll
feel almost like the snap of a finger
see you then